PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
I have to give this to you.
Basically OK, except you
didn't understand
it the first time.
OK.
Good morning.
Happy spring.
Happy April.
We're running a little late.
I'll try to finish chapter
nine today and start on
chapter ten.
Ashish may have chapter
ten here later.
If not, it'll be on the web.
So we've been talking about
convolutional codes.
Specifically rate 1/n
One input n outputs.
As you may imagine, there
are also rate k/n
convolutional codes.
Generalization to k
inputs n outputs.
These have not been so much used
in practice, because in
general, we're using these
binary codes in the power
limited regime, and
we want low rates.
So 1/n is a good rate.
1/2, 1/3, 1/4, or down to 1/6
are common kinds of rates.
So I haven't bothered to develop
the more elaborate
theory for rate k/n codes.
The rate 1/n codes,
just to review.
The code is simply defined as
the set of all possible output
sequences of a convolutional
encoder, whose N impulse
responses are written as an
n-tuple g of d as the inputs
range over all Laurent
sequences, bi-infinite sequences.
And what we showed last time
is that without loss of
generality or optimality, we
could always take this g of d
to be of a particular
canonical form.
Namely, the g of d could be
taken to be a set of n
polynomials, g_j of d, that
were relatively prime.
And for any code, you can find
such a canonical encoder by
its unique [UNINTELLIGIBLE] two
units, and specifies the
code, clearly, by this.
So that's a nice canonical
encoder to take.
It furthermore has the property
that there's an
obvious realization of
this encoder in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] register form
with nu memory units.
And therefore 2 to
the nu states.
And we will prove in chapter ten
that this is the minimal
possible encoder
for this code.
In other words, there are lots
of different encoders that
generate this code, but you
can't possibly encode it with
fewer than the state space of
dimension less than nu.
That's the way it's going
to sound in chapter ten.
So we haven't quite got there
yet, but it's a minimal
encoder, therefore,
in that sense.
All right.
Today we're going to go now and
exploit the finite state
structure of this code, to get
a very efficient maximum
likelihood sequence decoding
algorithm called the Viterbi
algorithm, which I'm sure
you've all heard of.
It's become very famous, not
only in this field, but really
in any place where you're trying
to observe a finite
state machine in memory-less
noise.
A finite state hidden markov
model, if you like.
And so now it's used, for
instance, in the detection of
genomes, where the exons end and
the introns start and so
forth, and the garbage is.
And people use it who have no
idea that it was originally a
digital communications
algorithm.
But it's a very obvious
It's come up in many different
forms, and Viterbi, in a way,
was just lucky to get
his name on it.
Because it would come up very
easily as soon as you pose the
problem correctly.
Let's start out with terminated
convolutional codes.
Which I forget whether I started
on this last time.
I think I may have.
But we'll start from
scratch again.
When I say terminated, I mean
that we're going to take only
a subset of the code words
that start at a
certain time --
say, time 0 --
continue for some finite
time, and then end.
And in this set up, with this
canonical encoder, it's
polynomial, the easy way to
specify that is to let u of d
be a finite sequence that
starts at time 0.
That's called a polynomial.
and let's restrict
its degree --
degree u of d less than k.
In other words, it looks like u0
plus u1 d plus so forth up
to uk minus 1 d.
Therefore I've chosen k, so I
really have k information bits
or input bits.
All right?
So I specify u0 through
uk minus 1.
I use that as the input
in my encoder.
What is then my code,
my truncated code,
let's call it ck --
that's not a very good notation,
but we'll use it
just for now --
will be the set of all u of d,
g of d such that u of d is
polynomial and the degree of
u of d is less than k.
OK.
So we ask what that code
is going to be.
And let's take some
simple examples.
Turns out when we terminate
codes, we always choose
polynomial encoders, so the code
will naturally collapse
back to the 0 state.
How long?
Nu time units after the
input stops coming in.
The outputs will be all 0 at
that point and forevermore.
The shift register will clear
itself out nu time units
later, and then they'll
be all 0.
So the code really starts
at time 0 and ends
at time k plus nu.
So we aren't going to worry, in
this case, whether the code
is non-catastrophic or not.
Here one of the principal
properties that we had was
this property guaranteed
non-catastrophic.
And in fact, is necessary
for non-catastrophicity.
So we spent a lot of time
talking about why that would
be a bad thing, to
be catastrophic.
OK.
But let's take a catastrophic
rate 1/1 encoder, which simply
we have g of d equals
1 plus d.
You remember this encoder
as nu equals 1.
The input looks like this.
uk, uk minus 1.
And we simply add these, yk.
So we get y of d equals
1 plus d u of d.
OK.
Now, if the input to this is a
finite sequence, a polynomial,
let's see what this code
can possibly be.
What the code's going
to look like.
The code's going to start
in state 0, at time 0.
So here's the time.
At the first time, we can either
get a 0 in our a 1 in,
and accordingly, it will
go to state 0 or 1.
At the second time, we can go
to state 0 with another 0 or
just state 1 with a 1.
If we get a 1 in and we're in
state 1, then the output is
going to be 0, and we'll
stay in state 1.
If we get a 0 in, the output
will be a 1, and we'll go back
to state 0.
So this is what a
typical trellis
section looks like here.
We have all possible
transitions
between the two states.
And so now it goes on for
a while like this.
Time invariantly.
There are 1, dot dot dot, and
then finally, at some time --
say this is time k, or maybe
it's time k minus 1 --
time index is a little fuzzy
here -- we don't
put any more 1s in.
We only put 0s on from
that time forward.
So we could have one more
transition back to state 0,
and then after that it just
stays in state 0 forevermore.
And this isn't very
interesting.
It was in time 0 all the
time before here.
It was in state 0 all the time
before there and put out 0s.
after here and put out 0s.
And this is clearly not
conveying any information.
Not an interesting
part of the code.
So we're going to consider the
code just to be defined over
these k plus 1 units of time.
And so y of d we're going
to consider to be a
polynomial of degree k.
Now we're going to assume
that they're k bits in.
Then we're going to wait one
more time to let the shift
register clear out,
which is nu.
And at that time, we're going
to take whatever y is, and
then we're going to
terminate it.
So if we consider this now, we
have a block code whose length
is the number of non-zero
coefficients of y of d.
So we have n equals k plus
1, we have k by design
information bits, and
what's the minimum
non-zero weight of this?
It's linear.
What's its minimum
non-zero weight,
or its minimum distance?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 1.
Show me a code word
of weight 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I claim the minimum
non-zero weight is 2 by
typical argument.
I have the all 0 sequence.
If I ever leave the all 0
sequence, I accumulate 1 unit
of Hamming weight.
And I need to ultimately come
back to the all 0 sequence,
because I've made everything
finite here.
So in this case, I can make
the argument that I always
have to come back to
the all 0 sequence.
Whenever I merge back into
the all 0 sequence, I'll
accumulate another
unit of weight.
So this is a code with
minimum distance 2.
Minimum non-zero weight 2.
And in fact, it's just the
single parity-check code of
length n equals k plus 1.
OK?
And if you ask yourself,
can you generate any --
this is supposedly the
even weight code.
It contains all even weight
k plus 1-tuples.
And I think you can convince
yourself that you can generate
any of these k plus 1 even
weight k-tuples.
In fact, the generator
matrix for this code.
Look.
Here's a set of generators.
1 1 is in the code.
0 1 1 is in the code.
0 0 1 1 in the code.
So here's a set of generators.
0 1 1.
Generator matrix for the
code looks like this.
We just go like that.
And with these k generators,
you can generate any even
weight code word.
So we get a kind of
convolutional form to the
generator matrix.
A sliding parity-check form
to the generator matrix.
OK.
So I assert that this is the
single parity-check code.
So here's a trellis
representation for a block code.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sure I've got the
time indices screwed up.
But I put in k bits.
I wait 1 more unit of time --
nu equals 1 --
for this to clear out.
So I get out k plus 1 bits.
Think of it in terms
of this here.
I put in k, the last input you
think of as necessarily being
0, and I take the outputs
here for k plus 1 times.
OK.
So first of all, a couple
points here.
AUDIENCE: In general, the length
will be k plus nu?
PROFESSOR: In general, length
will be k plus nu.
So let's write that down.
So in general, by terminating
a rate 1/n --
nu is called the constraint
length --
constraint length nu, or 2
to the nu state code --
convolutional code after k
inputs, we get a binary linear
block code whose parameters
are --
we have k information bits.
We have k plus nu non-trivial
output times.
At each output time, I
get n output bits.
So it's n times k plus nu
is the total effective
length of the code.
And the distance, we would have
to say, is greater than
or equal to the distance of the
block code is greater than
or equal to the distance of
the convolutional code.
Why?
Because all of the words in this
block code are actually
sequences in the convolutional
code.
I'm assuming here that the code
is not catastrophic, so
it's sufficient to look at all
the finite sequences in the
convolutional code.
All right.
And in general, the block code
distance is almost always
going to be equal to the
convolutional code distance.
And this is just for
finite code words.
So as another example, suppose
we take our standard rate 1/2,
nu equals 2, distance equals
5, convolutional code.
Our example 1 that we've
been using all along.
Suppose I terminate with
k equals 4, then I'm
going to get what?
I'm going to get a 2 times 6,
I'm going to get a 12, 4, 5
binary linear block code.
That is not so bad, actually.
There's a point that I'm
not going to make
very strongly here.
But terminated convolutional
codes can be good block codes.
And in fact, asymptotically,
by choosing the parameters
correctly, you can show that you
can get a random ensemble
of terminated convolutional
codes that is as good as the
best possible random ensemble
of block codes.
So terminated convolutional
codes is one way of
constructing optimal block codes
in the asymptotic limit.
These parameters aren't bad.
Here's a rate 1/3 code
with distance 5.
Not too long.
You know, you might compare
it to what?
The BCH code?
There's a 15 7 5 BCH code,
which is clearly better,
because it's higher rate.
But if you shorten this code,
you have to shorten this by 3,
this by 3 to keep
the distance.
You would get the same code.
So it's not optimum, but
it's not too bad.
And furthermore, from this
construction, you get a
trellis representation,
which in this case
would look like this.
It looks like the trellis that
we started to draw last time.
Sorry.
Doesn't look like that.
This guy goes down here,
this guy comes here,
this guy goes here.
This continues for a while.
And then finally, when we start
to enforce all zeros, we
only have one possible output
from each of these.
And we get a trellis that
looks like that.
All right?
Which is 1, 2, 3 --
I did it correctly for
this code, actually.
Because each of these
is going to have a
2-tuple output on it.
And that looked like 0,0
0,0 0,0 0,0 0,0.
Each of the information bits
causes a two-way branch, no
matter where you are
in the trellis.
So here's 1, here's 2,
here's 3, here's 4.
That's the end of them.
We wait for nu equal 2 to let
the states converge back to 0.
So that's a trellis
representation of this 12 4 5
block code.
OK.
I want to talk about terminated
block codes,
terminated trellis codes,
convolutional codes as block
codes, for two reasons.
One is to say we can get
block codes that way.
But the other is to introduce
the Viterbi algorithm for
terminated convolutional
codes.
I think it's easier first to
look at how the algorithm
works when you have a finite
trellis like this, and then
we'll go on and say, well, how
would this work if we let the
trellis become very long, or
in principle, infinite?
Would the Viterbi algorithm
still work?
And it becomes obvious
that it does.
So this is going to be a maximum
likelihood sequence
detection or decoding
algorithm.
We're going to assume that each
time here, we get to see
two things.
Corresponding to the two
bits we transmit.
So we transmit yk according
to which trellis
branch we're on --
y0 at this point -- and we
receive a 2-tuple r0.
If we were on a binary input
additive white Gaussian
channel, this would go into,
actually, the 2-PAM map, two
plus or minus alphas, and be
received as two real numbers.
And we do the same thing here.
y1, we receive r1, and so forth,
up to yk plus nu, or k
plus nu minus 1, I think it
is, rk plus nu minus 1.
OK.
So we have a transmit 2-tuple
and a received
2-tuple every time.
And we're going to assume that
the channel is memoryless so
that the probabilities of
receiving the various possible
received values, the
likelihoods, are independent
from time unit to time unit.
That's the only way
this works.
Then if I want to get the total
probability of r given
y, where now I'm talking about
over the whole block, this
factors into the probabilities
of rk given yk, yes?
That's what I'm going
to depend on.
This is what's called the
memoryless condition,
memoryless channel.
The transition probabilities do
not depend on what's been
sent or received in
previous blocks.
Or it's more convenient to use
the minus log likelihood
equals now the sum of the minus
log p of rk given yk.
So maximum likelihood is
equivalent to minimize the
neg-log likelihood.
OK.
I receive only one thing
in each time unit.
And each trellis branch
corresponds to transmitting a
specific thing.
So I can label each trellis
branch with the appropriate
minus log p of rk given yk.
Do you see that?
In other words, for this trellis
branch down here,
which is associated with y2
equals 0 1, or s of y2 equals
alpha minus alpha, suppose I
receive r2 equals r1, r2, I
would label this by, say, the
Euclidean distance between
what I transmitted for that
branch and what I received.
For instance, on the additive
white Gaussian channel, this
would simply be rk
minus s of yk.
The Euclidean distance
squared.
Or equivalently, minus the inner
product, the correlation
between rk and s of yk.
You know, these are equivalent
metrics.
Or on a binary symmetric
channel, might be the Hamming
distance between what I
received and what I
transmitted, both of which
would be binary
2-tuples, in this case.
It's just some measure
of distance --
Log likelihood distance,
Euclidean distance, Hamming
distance --
between the particular thing I
would have transmitted if I'd
been on this branch and the
particular thing that I
actually did receive.
So having received a whole block
of data, I can now put a
cost on each of these
branches.
What's the minus log likelihood
cost if I say that
the code word goes through
that branch?
What does it cost me?
All right.
Now what I'm basically depending
on is note, there's
a one-to-one map between
code words y and
c and trellis paths.
For this specific trellis up
here, how many paths are there
through the trellis?
Do you see that however I go
through the trellis, I'm going
to meet four two-way branches?
All right?
According to [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
there
are four yes-no questions.
It's a binary tree.
So there are 16 possible ways
to get through this trellis
from start to finish, if I view
it as a maze problem.
And they correspond --
I haven't labeled all
the branche --
but they do correspond to all
16 words in this block code.
So now what is maximum
likely decoding?
I want to find the one of those
16 words that has the
greatest likelihood, or the
least negative log likelihood,
over all of these 12 received
symbols or 6 received times.
So what will that be?
Once I've labeled each of these
branches with a log
likelihood cost, I simply want
to find the least cost path
through this trellis.
And that will correspond to
the most likely code word.
This is the essence of it.
Do you all see that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The independent
transmission allows me to
break it up into a
symbol-by-symbol or
time-by-time expression.
So I can simply cumulate over
this sum right here.
And I'm just looking for the
minimum sum over all the
possible ways I could get
through this trellis.
So now we translated this into
finding the minimum cost path
through a graph.
Through a graph with a very
special structure, nice
regular structure.
OK.
Once you've got that, then I
think it's very obvious how to
come up with a nice recursive
algorithm for doing that.
Here's my recursive algorithm.
I'm going to start computing
weights.
I'm going to start here.
I'm going to assign
weight zero here.
Right here I'm going to assign a
weight which is equal to the
cost of the best path to get
to that node in the graph.
In this case, it's just the
cost of that branch.
Similarly down here.
Similarly I proceed
to these four.
There's only one way to get to
each of these four, and I
simply add up what the
total weight is.
Now here's the first point where
it gets interesting,
where I have two possible ways
to get to this node.
One way is via these three
branches, and that has a
certain cost.
Another way is via these three
branches, and that has a
certain cost.
Suppose the cost of these three
branches is higher than
the cost of these
three branches.
Just pair-wise.
All right?
Claim that I can pick the
minimum cost path to this
node, throw away the other
possibility, and I can never
have thrown away something which
itself is part of the
minimum cost path through
the whole trellis.
Clearly.
Suppose this is the best
path from here to here.
This is worse.
X, X, X, X X. And now I find the
minimum cost path through
the whole trellis goes
through this node.
Say it's like that.
Could it have started
with this?
No.
Because I can always replace
this with a path that starts
with that and get
a better path.
So at this point, I can make a
decision between all the paths
that get to that node
and pick just one.
The best one that gets
to that node.
And that's called
the survivor.
This is really the key concept
that Viterbi introduced.
We only need to say one, the
best up to that time.
We need to do it for all the
2 to the nu possibilities.
So we have 2 to the nu survivors
at time k or time i,
whatever your time index is.
Used k for something else.
OK.
So I can throw away half
the possibilities.
Now each survivor, I remember
what its past history is, and
I remember what its cost
is to that point.
Now to proceed, the recursion
is to proceed one time unit
ahead, to add the incremental
cost -- say, to make a
decision here, I need to add
the incremental cost to the
two survivors that were
here and here.
So I add an incremental cost,
according to what these
branches are labeled with.
And now I find the best of these
two possibilities to get
to this node.
So the recursion is called an
ACS operation for add, we add
increments to each of these
paths, we compare which is the
best, and we select
the best one.
We keep that.
We throw away the other.
We now have a one unit longer
best path to this node and its
cost for all 2 the nu survivors
at time i plus 1.
And just proceeding in that way,
we go through until we
finally get to the
terminating node.
And at this point, when we've
found the best path to this
node, we've found the best path
through the whole trellis.
OK?
So that's all it is.
I believe it's just totally
obvious once you reduce it to
a search for a minimum cost
path through the trellis.
It's very well suited to the
application of convolutional
codes, because we really are
thinking of sending these bits
as a stream in time.
And at the receiver, you can
think of just proceeding
forward one unit of time, 2 to
the nu, add, compare, selects,
and we've got a new
set of survivors.
There are nice implications of
this that involve, you can
build a computer for every
node or for every pair of
nodes to do the ACS operation,
make a very fast recursion
through here.
So that's it.
That's the Viterbi algorithm
for terminated
convolutional codes.
Now let's ask about the
VIterbi algorithm for
unterminated convolutional
codes.
Suppose this trellis
becomes very long.
Across the whole page.
What are these survivors
going to look like?
Suppose we start from a definite
node here, and we've
got a four state convolutional
code, and we iterate and we
iterate and we iterate with
the Viterbi algorithm.
After a long time, somewhere out
here, we're going to have
four survivors and
their histories.
And I've greatly simplified,
but basically the histories
are going to look schematically
something --
I don't know -- could
be anything.
Look like this.
The point I'm illustrating here
is that the histories
will be distinct right
at this time.
They have to be, because
they're going to
four distinct stages.
But as you go backwards in
time, you will find they
merge, any two histories will
merge, at a certain time back.
And this is a probablistic
thing.
It depends on what's happening
on the channel and so forth.
But with high probability, they
will have merged not too
far back in time.
So even if we never get to a
final node, even if we just
let this process continue
forever, at this point we can
say, we can make a definite
decision at this time.
Right?
Because all survivors
start with a common
initial part, up to here.
So one way to operate the
Viterbi algorithm would be
just to, at this
point, say, OK.
I'm going to put out everything
before this time.
No matter how long I run the
decoder, the first part of it
is always going to
be this part.
So these are definitely decided
up to this time.
And then I still don't
know about here.
I'm going to have to go
a little bit further.
You proceed further, and after
a while, you find more that's
definitely done.
In practice, that would lead
to a sporadic output rate.
That isn't really
what you want.
So in practice what you do is
you establish a decision
delay, delta.
And what you put out is you hope
that 99.999% of the time,
that if you look back delta on
all the survivors, they will
all be a common path,
delta back here.
So there's a very
high probability
you will have converged.
And so simply at this time, you
put out what you decided
on delta time units earlier.
Next time you put out
the next one.
So you get a nice, regular,
synchronous stream of data
coming out of here.
Every so often, it may happen
that you get out to here and
you still haven't
made a decision.
Then you have to do something.
And it really doesn't matter
terribly much what you do.
You might pick the guy who has
the best metric at this time,
or you simply might say, well,
I'm always going to pick the
one that goes to all zeros.
That wouldn't be symmetric.
You can make any decision
you like.
And you could be wrong.
But you pick delta large enough
so that the probability
of this happening is very rare,
and this just adds a
little bit to your error
probability, and as long as
the probability of making an
error because of this kind of
operation is much lower than
your probability of making an
ordinary decoding error, then
you're going to be OK.
For convolutional codes way back
at the beginning of time,
people decided that a decision
delay a 5 times nu, 5 times
the constraint length, was
the right rule of thumb.
And that's been the rule of
thumb for rate 1/n codes
forever after.
The point is, delta should
be a lot more than nu.
You know, after one constraint
length, you certainly won't
have converged.
After five constraint lengths,
you're highly
likely to have converged.
And theoretically, the
probability of not converging
goes down exponentially
with delta.
So big enough is
going to work.
And a final point is that
sometimes, you really care
that what you put out to
be a true code word.
In that case, if you get to this
situation, you have to
make a choice, you make a choice
here, then you have to
actually eliminate all the
survivors that are not
consistent with that choice.
And you can do that simply by
putting an infinite metric on
this guy here.
Then he'll get wiped out as
soon as he's compared with
anybody else.
And that will ensure that
whatever you eventually put
out, you keep the
sequence being a
legitimate code sequence.
So that's a very fine point.
OK.
So there really isn't any
serious problem with letting
the Viterbi algorithm run
indefinitely in time once
you've got it started.
How do you get it started?
Suppose you came online and
you simply had a stream of
outputs, transmitted from a
convolutional code over a
channel, and you didn't know
what state to start in.
How do you use synchronize
to a starting state?
Well, this is not hard either.
Basically you start, you're in
one of four states, or 2 to
the nu states.
You don't know which one.
Let's just give them all cost
0 and start decoding, using
the four state trellis.
And we just start receiving
2-tuples from here on.
We get rk, r k plus
1, and so forth.
So how should we start?
Well, we'll just start
like that.
And we get sort of the mirror
image of this --
that after a time, these will
all converge to a single path.
Or after a time, when we're way
down here, this is what
the situation will look like.
These things will each have a
different route over here, but
they will have converged
in here.
There will be a long path over
which they're all converged,
and then towards the end,
they'll be unrooted again.
OK.
Well, that's fine.
What does that mean
in practice?
That means we make errors during
the synchronization.
But we say we're synchronized
when we get this case where
all the paths going to all the
current survivors have a
common central stage.
And how long does it take
to synchronize?
Again, by analysis, it's exactly
this same delta again.
The probability of not being
synchronized after delta goes
down exponentially with delta
in exactly the same way.
It's just a mirror image from
one end to the other.
So from a practical point of
view, this is no problem.
And just starting the Viterbi
decoder up, with arbitrary
metrics here, and after five
constraint lengths, if you
like, it's highly likely to
have gotten synchronized.
You'll make errors for five
constraint lengths and after
that, you'll be OK, as though
you knew the starting state.
So the moral is, no problem.
You can just set up the Viterbi
algorithm and let it run.
The costs will all, of course,
increase without bound, which
is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You can always renormalize them,
subtract a common cost
from all of them.
That won't change anything.
Keep them within running time.
So we don't need to terminate
convolutional codes in order
to run the Viterbi algorithm.
We just let it self-synchronize
and we make
decisions with some
decision delay.
And the additional problems
that we have
are very, very small.
There are no additional
problems.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: At this point?
Well, notice that we don't know
that we've synchronized
until we've continued further,
and we've got --
you know, where we've really
synchronized is when we see
that every survivor path
has the common root.
So at that point, there is
really only one path here.
And we can say that the
synchronized part is
definitely decoded.
And we can't really say too
much about this out here,
because this depends on what's
happened out in the past.
So you say this is erasures,
if you like.
The stuff that we're pretty sure
has a high probability of
being wrong.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There is
only one decoded
path during this interval.
AUDIENCE: But before that
interval there are branches
and so on right.
PROFESSOR: Well here, we
don't know anything.
Here we know the results
of one computation.
What are you suggesting?
Just pick the best one
at that point?
AUDIENCE: And finally after
you reach the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: And finally?
I'm just not sure
exactly what the
logic is of your algorithm.
It's clear for this, it wouldn't
make any difference
if we just started off
arbitrarily so, we're going to
start in the zero state.
And we only allow things to
Well, we'll eventually get
to this path anyway.
So it really doesn't matter
how you start.
You're going to have garbage for
a while, and then you're
going to be OK.
There's no point in doing
anything more
sophisticated than that.
I don't want to discuss what
you're suggesting, because I
think there's a flaw in it.
Try to figure out what time
you're going to make this
decision at.
OK.
Do we all understand the
Viterbi algorithm?
Yes?
Good.
We can easily program it up.
There will be an exercise
on the homework.
But now you can all do the
Viterbi algorithm.
All right.
So --
and oh.
What's the complexity of
the Viterbi algorithm?
What is the complexity?
We always want to be talking
about performance versus
complexity.
So it's a recursive algorithm.
We do exactly the same
operations every unit of time.
What do the operations
consist of?
They consist of add,
compare, select.
How many additions to
we have to make?
Additions are basically equal
to the number of branches in
each unit of time in the
trellis, which is 2
to the nu plus one.
Is that clear?
We have 2 to the nu states.
Two branches out of, two
branches into each state,
always for rate one.
So we have 2 to the nu
plus 1 additions.
We get 2 the nu compares,
one for each state.
Which is really, you can
consider the select to be part
of the compare.
Overall, you can say the
complexity is of the order of
2 to the nu or 2 to
the nu plus 1.
This is the number of states
or the state complexity.
This is the number
of branches.
I will argue a little bit
later that the branch
complexity is really
more fundamental.
You've got to do at least one
thing for each branch.
So in different set up,
the branch complexity.
But these are practically the
same thing, and so we say that
the complexity of the Viterbi
algorithm is basically like
the number of states.
We have a four state encoder,
the complexity's like four, it
goes up exponentially with
the constraint length.
This says, this is going to be
nice, as long as we have short
constraint length.
For longer constraint lengths,
you know, a constraint length
20, it's going to be a pretty
horrible algorithm.
So we can only use the Viterbi
algorithm relatively short
constraint length codes,
relatively
small numbers of states.
The biggest Viterbi algorithm
that I'm aware has ever been
built is a 2 the 14th
state algorithm.
The so-called big Viterbi
decoder out at JPL.
It was used for the Galileo
space missions.
It's in a rack that big.
I'm sure nowadays you could
practically get it on a chip,
and you could maybe do
2 the 20th states.
But so this exponential
complexity, in computer
science terms, not really
what we want.
But when we're talking about
moderate complexity decoders,
these really have proved to be
the most effective, and become
the standard moderate
complexity decoder.
The advantage is that we can
do true maximum likelihood
decoding on a sequence basis,
using soft decisions, using
whatever reliability information
the channel has,
as long as it's memoryless.
So last topic is to talk
about performance.
How are we going to evaluate
the performance of
convolutional codes?
You remember what we
did on block codes?
We basically looked at the
pairwise error probability
between block code words, we
then did the union bound,
based on the pairwise
error probabilities.
And we observed that the union
bound was typically dominated
by the minimum distance error
events, and so we get the
union bound estimate, which
was purely based on the
minimum distance possible
errors.
And we can do exactly the
same thing in the
convolutional case.
Convolutional case, again,
is a linear code.
That means it has the group
property, has symmetry such
that the distances from every
possible code sequence to all
other code sequences are going
to be the same, since we're
talking on a long or possibly
infinite sequence basis.
And we need to be just a little
bit more careful about
what an error consists of.
We need to talk about
error events.
And this is a simple concept.
Let us again draw a path
corresponding to the
transmitted code words.
A very long path, potentially
infinite, but it is some
definite sequence.
And let's run it through a
memory list channel, use the
Viterbi algorithm, and we're
going to get some received
code word, or decoded
code word.
This is one place where you
might want to insist that the
Viterbi algorithm actually
put out a code word.
What is that going
to look like?
Well, if you're running
normally, the received code
word is going to equal
the transmitted code
word most the time.
Except it's going
to make errors.
And what will the errors
look like?
They'll look like a branch off
through the trellis, and then
eventually a reemerging
into the same state.
And similarly, you go on longer,
and you might have
another error.
And any place where there's
a difference --
should have done a different
color here --
any place where there's
difference, this is called an
error event.
So what I'm illustrating is a
case when we had two disjoint
error events.
Is that concept clear?
We're going to draw the trellis
paths corresponding
the transmitted code word and
the decoded code word.
Wherever they diverge over a
period of time, we're going to
call it an error event.
But eventually they will
re-merge again.
So it could be a short time.
Can't be any shorter than the
constraint length plus 1.
That would be the minimum
length error event.
Could be a longer time.
Unbounded, actually.
OK.
What is going to be the
probability of an error event
starting at some time?
And when I say an error event
starting at time k, let's
suppose I've been going along
on the transmitted path, and
the decoder has still
got that there.
I'm asking, what is the
probability that this code
word is actually more likely
on a maximum likelihood
sequence detection basis
than this one?
Well, simply the probability
that the received sequence is
closer to this one
than this one.
We know how to analyze that
for a finite differences.
What is the difference here?
The difference, call this y
of d and this y hat of d.
What is y of d minus
y hat of d?
We'll call that e of d.
This is a code word.
This is a decoded code word.
So the error event has
to be a code word.
Right?
Decoder made a mistake.
The mistake has to
be a code word.
So we're asking, what is the
probability that y of d sent y
hat of d decoded, where
y hat of d equals y
of d plus e of d?
We'll just ask for that
particular event.
This is the probability that
r of d closer to y hat
of d than y of d.
Now, making a big leap.
This is equal to --
we're just talking about two
sequences in Euclidean space.
All that matters is
the Euclidean
distance between them.
What is the Euclidean distance
between them?
It's 4 alpha squared times the
weight of this error event,
the Hamming weight of
this error event.
And so if you remember how to
calculate pairwise error
probabilities, this is just
alpha squared D over sigma
squared, where D is the
distance of e of d.
The weight, the Hamming
weight of e of d.
Call it sigma squared.
Remember something that
looked like that?
So once again, we go from the
Hamming weight of a possible
error event to a Euclidean
weight, which is 4 alpha
squared times the
Hamming weight.
We actually take the square root
of that and we only need
to make an error, a noise
of half of that length.
So that's where the
4 disappears.
And we just get q of d squared
over sigma squared, where d is
the distance to the
decision boundary.
Compressing a lot of steps,
but it's all something you
felt you knew well a
few chapters ago.
So the union bound would simply
be the sum over all
error events in the code
such that the start --
so e of d is --
you want them to start
at time 0, say.
Let's ask for the probably
of an error event
starting at time 0.
So we want it to be polynomial,
have no non-zero
negative coefficients, and have
the coefficient at time 0
be 1, or not 0.
I'm doing this very roughly.
Of q to the square root of alpha
squared times the weight
Hamming of e of d over
sigma squared.
Just as before.
So to get the union bound, we
sum up over the weights of all
sequences that start
at time 0.
Let's do it for our
favorite example.
Suppose g of d is 1 plus d
squared, 1 plus d plus d
squared, then what are the
possible e of d's that I'm
talking about?
I have this itself.
1 plus d squared, 1 plus
d plus d squared.
This is weight equal to 5.
What's my next possible
error event?
Would be 1 plus d times this.
So it's going to be a table.
We have g of d, 1 plus d times
g of d, which is equal to 1
plus d plus d squared plus d
cubed, 1 plus d cubed, that
has weight equals 6.
What's my next longer one?
1 plus d squared times g of d
equals 1 plus d fourth, 1 plus
d plus d third plus d fourth,
that has weight 6.
1 plus d plus d squared
times g of d.
1 plus d plus --
this is 1 plus d plus --
plus d third, plus d forth.
I may be making a
mistake here.
1 plus d squared
plus d fourth.
It's hard to do this by
hand after a while.
OK.
Notice, we start tabulating all
the error events, which I
can do in order of the degree of
u of d, always keeping the
non-zero, the time 0
term equal to 1.
So this is the only
one of length 1.
This is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
of degree 0.
This is the only one
of degree 1.
There are two of them
of degree 2.
There will be four of them of
degree 3, and so forth.
So I can lay out what all the
error events could be, and I
look at what their
weights are.
Here's my minimum weight
error event.
Then I have two of weight
six and so forth.
So the union bound, I'd be
adding up this term.
I'd get one term where the
weight is 5, two where the
weight is 6, I don't know how
many where the weight is 7.
I happen to know there
were only two
weight 6 error events.
And you simply have to find out
what the weight profile is
and put it in the union bound.
Or you can use the union bound
estimate, which is simply --
let's just take k nd, the number
of error events of
minimum weight d, times q to
the square root of alpha
squared d, where d equals min
weight over sigma squared.
OK.
In this case, nd equals
1, d equals 6.
Let me take this one
step further.
nd times q to the square
root of --
what is sigma squared
equals n0 over 2?
And Eb equals n times
alpha squared.
The energy per transmitted
bit is alpha squared.
We're going to transmit n bits
for every information bit.
So plugging those in, I get 2d
over n times Eb over N0, which
is again of the form nd q to the
square root of 2 times the
coding gain of the code
times Eb over N0.
Bottom line is I get precisely
the same performance analysis,
or I get a nominal
coding gain of --
in general, it's kd over n.
If it were a rate k over n
code, since we're only
considering rate 1 over n codes,
it's just d over n.
And I get an error coefficient
which equals the number of
weight d code words,
starting time 0.
Of course an error event could
start at any time.
If there are nd starting
at time 0, how many
start at time 1?
Time invariant code.
So it's going to be the same
numbers could possibly
start at time 1.
So what I'm computing here is
the probability of an error
event starting at a
particular time.
For this particular code,
what do I have?
I have one event of weight 5.
So the nominal coding gain
is 5 over n, which is 2.
Which is --
5 is 7 dB, 2 is 3 dB,
so this is 4 dB.
That's pretty good.
Nominal coding gain of 4 dB with
only a four state code.
Obviously a very simple
decoder for this code.
And what is kd equals 1?
That implies --
again, we have the same argument
about whatever the
error coefficient is.
You could plot this curve.
The larger the error coefficient
is, the more the
curve moves up, and
therefore over.
You get an effective coding
gain which is less.
But this means since it's 1,
you don't have to do that.
The effective coding gain
is the same as the
nominal coding gain.
It's still 4 dB.
So it's a real 4 dB of coding
gain for the simple little two
state code.
This code compares very directly
with the 8 4 4
Reed-Muller code, block code.
This code also has rate 1/2.
It has the same rate.
We'll see that it also has a
four-state trellis diagram.
But it only has distance four,
which means its nominal coding
gain is only 2, 3 dB.
And furthermore, it has 14
minimum weight words, which
even dividing by 4 to get the
number per bit, there's still
a factor of 3, still going to
cost us another couple of
tenths of a dB.
Its effective coding gain is
only about 2.6 or 2.7 dB.
All right?
So this code has much better
performance for about the same
complexity as this code,
at the same rate.
And this tends to be typical.
Convolutional codes just beat
block codes when you compare
them in this way.
Notice that we're assuming
maximum likelihood decoding.
We don't yet have a maximum
likelihood decoding algorithm
for this code.
We'll find for this code, we can
also decode it using the
Viterbi algorithm with
a four state decoder
comparable to this one.
So it would be, I would say,
for maximum likelihood
decoding --
about same complexity.
But we simply get much better
performance with the
convolutional.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Say again?
AUDIENCE: What happened
to the k?
PROFESSOR: Why is
k equal to 1?
Which k?
Over here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah. kd
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
We're only considering
rate 1/n codes.
If it were a rate k/n code, we
would get k over n, because
this would be n over k
times alpha squared.
Just the same as before.
In fact, I just want to wave my
hand, say, everything goes
through as before.
As soon as you get the error
event concept, you can reduce
it to the calculation of
pairwise error probabilities,
and then the union bound
estimate is as before.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, I had my
little trellis here.
And how long in real time
does it take for
two paths to merge?
An error event has got to take
at least nu plus 1 time units
for two paths to diverge
and then merge
again in the trellis.
Is that clear?
Or put another way, the lowest
degree of any possible error
event is nu, which means it
actually takes place over nu
plus 1 time units.
OK?
From this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why is
the lowest --?
I'm taking g of d --
the definition of nu is what?
The maximum degree of g of d.
OK?
So if that's so, then the
shortest length error event is
1 times g of d, which takes nu
plus 1 time units to run out.
So error events have to be at
least this long, and then they
can be any integer length
longer than that.
You don't look totally happy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You understand?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How I see it
from this diagram?
Where have I got a picture
of a trellis?
Here I've got a picture
of a trellis.
I've defined an error
event by taking a
transmitted code word.
It's a code sequence.
This is supposed to represent
some path through the trellis.
There's one-to-one
correspondence between code
sequences and trellis paths.
Then I find another code
sequence, which is the one I
actually decided on.
Call that the decoded
code sequence.
And I say, what's the minimum
length of time they could be
diverged from one another?
All right?
Let's take this particular
trellis.
What's the minimum length
of time any two paths --
say, here's the transmitted
path.
Suppose I try to find another
path that diverges from it?
Here's one.
Comes back to it.
Another one.
I say that the minimum length
of time it could
take is nu plus 1.
Why?
Because the difference between
these two paths is itself a
code sequence, is therefore
a non-zero polynomial
multiple of g of d.
OK?
Same argument.
OK.
So I guess I'm not going to get
into chapter 10, so I'll
discourse a little bit more
about convolutional codes
versus block codes.
How do you construct
convolutional codes, actually?
You see that really, what you
want to do is to first of all,
maximize the minimum distance
for certain constraint length.
Subject to that, you want to
minimize the number of minimum
distance words.
You want to, in fact, get the
best distance profile.
Is there any block codes?
We had nice, algebraic
ways of doing this.
Roots of polynomials,
Reed-Solomon codes.
We could develop an algebraic
formula which told us what the
minimum distance was.
Do we have any nice algebraic
constructions like that
convolutional code?
No.
Basically, you've just got to
search all the possible
polynomials where the maximum
degree is nu.
Take pairs of polynomials.
If you want a rate 1/2 code of
degree nu, there's not that
many things you have
to search.
All right?
You just take all possible pairs
of binary polynomials of
degree nu or less, making sure
that you don't take any two
which have a common divisor, an
untrivial common divisor,
so you can wipe those out.
You want to make sure that
the constant term is 1.
There's no point in sliding one
over so it has a larger
constant term than 1.
But subject to those provisos,
you simply try all pairs g1,
g2, and you just do --
as soon as you've assured
yourself they're not
catastrophic, they don't have a
common divisor, then you can
just list, you know, the finite
code words are going to
be the ones that are
generated by
finite information sequences.
So you can just list all the
code words, as I've started to
do up here.
Or since the trellis is, in
fact, a way of listing all the
code words, there's a one-to-one
correspondence
between code words and trellis
paths, you can just start
searching through the trellis
and you will quickly find all
the minimum weight code words,
and thereby establish the
minimum distance, the
weight profile as
far out as you like.
And you choose the best.
You try all possibilities.
So Joseph Odenwalder did this
as soon as people recognized
that short convolutional codes
could be practical, and he
published the tables back in his
PhD thesis in '69, so he
got a PhD thesis out of this.
It wasn't that hard, it's done
once and for all, and the
results are in the notes.
The tables.
And you can see from the
tables that in terms of
performance versus moderate
complexity,
things go pretty well.
Here's this four state code.
It already gets you 4 dB of
effective coding gain.
To get to 6 dB of effective
coding gain, you need to go up
to about 64 states.
First person to do this was
Jerry Heller at Jet Propulsion
Laboratory.
Again, about '68, immediately
after Viterbi proposed his
algorithm in '67, Heller was the
first to go out and say,
well, let's see how
these perform.
So he found a good 64 state
rate 1/2 code, and he did
probability of error versus Eb
over N0, and he said, wow.
I get a 6 dB coding gain.
And Viterbi had no idea that his
algorithm would actually
be useful in practice.
He was just using it
to make a proof.
And he didn't even know
it was optimum.
But he's always given the credit
to Heller for realizing
it could be practical.
And so that 64 state rate 1/2
code with Viterbi algorithm
decoding became very popular
in the '70s.
Heller and Viterbi and Jacobs
went off to form a company
called Linkabit.
And for the technology of the
time, that seemed to be a very
appropriate solution.
You see you get approximately
the same thing as a
rate 1/3, rate 1/4.
If you go lower in rate you
can do marginally better.
If you are after tenths of
a dB, it's worthwhile.
Later in the decade, is the best
way to get more gain to
go to more and more complicated
convolutional codes?
No.
The best way is to use the
concatenated idea.
Once you use these maximum
likelihood decoders, the
Viterbi decoders, to get your
error rate down to 10 to the
minus 3 or something, 1 in 1000,
at that point you have
very few errors, and you can
apply then an outer code to
clean up the error events
that do occur.
You see, you're going to get
bursts of errors in your
decoded sequence.
It's a very natural idea to have
an outer code, which is
based on gf of 256,
say, 8 bit bytes.
And so a Reed-Solomon code comes
along and cleans up the
errors that do occur, and drives
the error probability
down to 10 to the minus 12, to
whatever you like it, with
very little redundancy, very
little additional cost.
So that became the standard
approach for space
communications in the '70s
and indeed '80s.
I've already mentioned that
around '90, they went up to
this 2 to the fourteenth
state Viterbi decoder.
They went to much more powerful
outer codes, much cleverer.
And they were able to get to
within about 2 or 3 dB of the
Shannon limit.
And that was the
state-of-the-art on the eve of
the discovery of turbo codes,
which is where we're going in
all of this.
So from a practical point
of view, in the moderate
complexity regime, simple
convolutional codes with
moderate complexity Viterbi
decoding are the best still
that anybody knows how to do.
They have all these
system advantages.
They work with nice synchronous
streams of
traffic, which is what you want
for data transmission.
They use soft decisions.
They use any kind
of reliability
information you have.
They're not limited
by hard decisions.
They're not limited by bounded
systems as the algebraic
schemes are.
So it just proved to be a better
way to go on channels
like the additive white Gaussian
noise channel.
OK.
So we didn't get into
chapter 10.
We'll start that next time.